les avantages c'est vraiment que la
population elle participe à la vie
politique elle donne son avis donc elle
est sensible à ça donne aussi un certain
sens civique
et puis on a vraiment l'impression de ne
pouvoir jouer un rôle pas seulement tous
les quatre ans où tous les cinq ans
lorsqu'on élit des parlementaires on
élit des gens à l'assemblée fédérale
mais vraiment dans la vie quotidienne et
c'est vrai que l'on peut voter à la fois
sur des grands enjeux liés à la
fiscalité liée à la migration mais sur
des choses qui peuvent paraître plus
anecdotiques comme les cordes vaches
comme les pistes cyclables des choses
comme ça mais ça donne vraiment
l'impression de participer au quotidien
après dans les aspects négatifs c'est
que peut-être en suisse on vote un peu
trop souvent on votre quatre fois par
année
parfois sur des objets très technique on
est obligé chaque fois qu'on réforme la
constitution de voter il a parfois c'est
vrai que peut-être que sur un certain
nombre d'objets on pourrait éviter des
votes qui sont des fois très très clair
mais de façon globale je pense que c'est
une très bonne chose et ça permet si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec une
décision qui a été prise par les
autorités politiques au niveau suisse
cinquante mille signatures doivent être
récoltées ce qui n'est pas énormément
et puis si vous avez envie d'introduire
un objet quelque chose qui vous tient à
coeur une proposition avec cent mille
signatures au point fr est là aussi
finalement à cent mille signatures c'est
pareil en alors ça c'est un peu la
question qu'on se pose maintenant c'est
ce qu'on ne devrait pas augmenter le
nombre de signatures pour quand même
prendre ça un petit peu plus difficile
puisque intéressant aussi au niveau
système suisse et vous avez ça c'est sur
le plan fédéral ces initiatives et ses
répondants mais elle existe aussi au
niveau des cantons et des communes même
des villes c'est à dire que dans votre
ville vous pouvez vous opposer à une
décision proposée aussi quelque chose de
nouveau
donc encore une fois ça donne vraiment
l'impression que on peut bouger les
choses et je pense qu'il ya mois
d'éloignement comme ça entre la société
et puis les politiques
est ce que le danger c'est pas du
populisme oui et non on regarde au final
finalement il ya très peu d'initiatives
qui passe alors y en a une qui était
très populiste qui a passé c'était
l'interdiction des minarets alors qu'il
y avait pratiquement qu'un minarets en
suisse
on va probablement voter prochainement
sur une initiative interdisant la burqa
alors que les fêtes c'est pas un
problème qui se pose vraiment la suisse
mais après ce genre d'initiative c'est
assez rare qu'elles passent donc il ya
quand même tout humain pouvoir
d'explication qui se fait
que ce soit par le biais des médias par
le biais des partis politiques etc qui
fait que très franchement il ya peu
d'initiatives dit populiste qui peuvent
passer la rampe
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
les suisses ont suffisamment formés
politiquement pour comprendre les
tenants et les aboutissants de toutes
les prestations alors pas de tout temps
parce qu'effectivement il y en a qui
sont très techniques on voit aussi au
niveau du taux de participation de
participation n'est pas jamais les 50%
pratiquement donc là ça montre que l'on
pourrait augmenter un peu l'exigence
aussi et c'est vrai que je pense qu'il
ya certains sujets qui sont compliqués
mais de façon globale je pense que l'
oblige quand même les suisses à
s'intéresser que ce soit par le biais
des médias mais aussi dans les écoles
c'est vrai que ces thèmes politiques
sont d'excellents thèmes qui peuvent
être utilisés en histoire un instruction
civique etc
pour sensibiliser les gens la population
à aux questions politiques
est-ce que aussi ce type de consultation
peut être détournée notamment par les
partis politiques pour faire un peu
mousser avant les élections l'assuré on
va avoir des élections à tout bientôt
et en période électorale tous azimuts
les partis lancent des initiatives
parfois aussi des référendums parce que
c'est une très très bonne manière
d'occuper le terrain on avait vu par
exemple la gauche avant les dernières
élections fédérales avaient lancé
beaucoup d'initiatives il certaines
avaient même été retiré parce qu'il ya
un moment donné ça permet de mobiliser
les troupes et où un moment donné on le
retire mais c'est aussi très intéressant
avec les initiatives de référendum c'est
pas forcément le résultat final c'est
que de toute manière lorsqu'il ya
l'initiative ou lorsqu'il ya un
référendum une évaluation politique qui
est faite
le gouvernement par exemple où le
parlement peut dire ouh la la cette
initiative a des chances de passer
devant le peuple référendum pourrait
passer donc on va proposer un
contre-projet où on va prendre déjà un
certain nombre de mesures
donc la plupart du temps l'initiative
est là de toute façon un résultat
concret parce qu'on va faire en sorte
que ce qui inquiète les gens puissent
être modifiés un peu autrement
et puis déjà ça provoque un débat
général ah oui il ya un débat général et
c'est vrai que du coup bah ya beaucoup
de débats qui se font vient de voter la
en décembre on a déjà une votation sur
l'aménagement du territoire
en février on en a deux autres ont mais
qui concerne à la fois les armes à la
fois les assurances sociales
position des entreprises on connaît tout
le temps tout le temps en débat l'une
des dernières votations 7 au mois de
mars sur le no billag où il était
question de la redevance tirer et du
service public audiovisuel dont vous
faites partie
et là vous avez eu très peur vous ici à
la rts et ça s'est plutôt bien passé
puisque à plus de 70%
il a été dit effectivement que on ne
supprimaient pas le service public donc
pour nous c'est effectivement quelque
chose de pas très favorable mais là
aussi on voit qu'il y avait déjà un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
prises on s'est rendu compte que la
population voulait un service public
différent il ya un certain nombre aussi
d'économie qui ont été annoncées donc
même s'il ya eu un résultat très peur à
70% il ya quand même des mesures qui ont
été prises
puisqu'il y avait une initiative dont il
y avait une préoccupation d'une partie
de la population donc sans ses
consultations populaires vous avez
l'impression que la démocratie suisse ne
fonctionnerait pas tout à fait pareil
non je pense qu'on a besoin aussi vu le
système suisse avec avec les quatre
longues avec eux c'est vrai un pouvoir
très fort dans les différentes régions
je pense qu'on a vraiment besoin de ça
et c'est aussi cette démocratie qui nous
unit parce qu'on n'a pas forcément les
mêmes les mêmes stars on regarde pas les
mêmes séries télévisées on ne regarde
pas les mêmes séries télévisées etc
par contre on vote sur les mêmes objets
vous avez l'impression qu'en france on
aurait intérêt à importer ce modèle au
moins pour les référendum et
d'irritation oui c'est vrai que pour
nous on a l'impression que quand même
des objets très important qu'on débat en
france et où la population pas son avis
à dire est que finalement c'est
seulement tous les cinq ans au moment de
la présidentielle que l'on voit un peu
les fronts mais qu'après il ya des
sujets de société des sujets de
politique de fond les sujets de
politique européenne et cetera où la
population ça pouvait donner son avis
elle se sentira peut-être plus proche
est peut-être que du coup elle
attendrait pas cinq ans pour changer de
gouvernement ou pour occuper les
ronds-points ou alors pour occuper leur
poids et ça c'est vrai que c'est une
grande différence et il ya aussi des
manifestations en suisse est aussi
souvent des manifestations qui sont
d'ailleurs en lien avec une votation on
mobilise
juste avant une votation la population
se déplace dans la rue mais on en a
beaucoup moins
notamment parce que voilà ses moyens ses
autres moyens politiques pour y remédier